And we've just slid past it. Fan favorite here, folks. Jason Turner, host of CppCast from, I believe, episode 4 to 349. I want to clarify some of my earlier statements. For legal reasons, I have to say those were jokes. I like all podcasts equally well. We caught the Pokemon before. I don't know.
我们刚刚滑过了它。各位，这是粉丝最爱。Jason Turner，CppCast 的主持人，我想是从第 4 集到第 349 集。我想澄清一下我之前的一些言论。出于法律原因，我必须说那些是开玩笑的。我同样喜欢所有的播客。我们之前抓到了宝可梦。我不知道。
I didn't actually play Pokemon. So did they hop back into a forest or something welcome to adsp the podcast episode 206 recorded on october 11 2024 my name is connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we interview both keynote speakers live from C++ Under the Sea, as well as three other guests, Kun Pop, Jan Williams, and briefly, Jonathan Mueller again. Introduce yourself, Jan, or I'll hand the mic to Bryce and then introduce yourself. Tell us how you enjoyed the inaugural edition of C++ Under the Sea. So in serious face, introduce yourself. I don't think you've been on the podcast before. I haven't.
我其实没玩过宝可梦。所以他们是跳回森林里去了还是怎么着？欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 206 集，录制于 2024 年 10 月 11 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Bryce 一起，现场采访两位来自“C++ Under the Sea”的主题演讲嘉宾，以及其他三位嘉宾：Kun Pop、Jan Williams，还有再次简短露面的 Jonathan Mueller。Jan，请自我介绍一下，否则我就把麦克风交给 Bryce，让他介绍你。告诉我们你对首届“C++ Under the Sea”大会的感受。严肃点，自我介绍一下。我觉得你之前没上过这个播客。我没上过。
My name is Jan Wilmans. I'm a software architect for Vimac. Yeah. What can I tell about myself? I also do C++ coaching. So, yeah, that's it a bit. I have a website called nullpointer.nl where you can find some information. Nullpointer.nl.
我叫 Jan Wilmans。我是 Vimac 的软件架构师。是的。我能介绍些什么呢？我也做 C++ 教练。所以，嗯，差不多就是这样。我有一个网站叫 nullpointer.nl，你可以在上面找到一些信息。Nullpointer.nl。
That's a good domain name. Did you teach a course at this conference? I did not. I generally don't teach courses uh for the public just inside the company ah okay interesting and so what's what what does the company that you work for whose name i'm not going to try to pronounce vymac it's not too difficult i think wasn't that bad what do they do oh we make a quality inspection system for glass. So vials, syringes, that kind of thing.
那是个不错的域名。你在这个会议上教过课吗？我没有。我通常不公开授课，只在公司内部教。啊，好的，很有趣。那么你工作的这家公司——名字我就不试着读了，Vymac——它做什么的？其实不难读，我觉得没那么糟。他们做什么？哦，我们制造玻璃质量检测系统。比如西林瓶、注射器之类的东西。
Medical glass. I have noticed that glass and mirrors seems to be a very Dutch thing. Like the mirrors that go into the lithography machines, they make them in the Netherlands. And for a lot of the telescopes, they make the big mirrors them in the netherlands and like for like a lot of the telescopes they make the big mirrors here in the netherlands like what is the dutch obsession with glass i don't know the answer to that question but um yeah we focus on the uh the quality of glass and not the production of glass let's say so yeah So we basically pick up products, rotate them,
医用玻璃。我注意到玻璃和镜子似乎是非常荷兰的东西。比如光刻机里的镜子，它们是在荷兰制造的。还有很多望远镜，它们的大镜子也是在荷兰制造的。就像很多望远镜的大镜子都是在这里制造的。荷兰人对玻璃有什么执念吗？我不知道这个问题的答案，但是，嗯，是的，我们专注于玻璃的质量，而不是玻璃的生产，可以这么说。所以，是的，我们基本上是拿起产品，旋转它们，
make sort of Google Maps of the outside of the surface of the glass, and then do image processing to find flaws. So cracks, bubbles, that kind of thing. And also we use optical setups to see if there are stress, if there are signs of stress in the glass. So that means if there's stress in glass, then it breaks when you drop it, basically. So it's fragile.
制作出玻璃表面外部的“谷歌地图”，然后进行图像处理以发现缺陷。比如裂纹、气泡之类的东西。我们还使用光学装置来观察玻璃中是否有应力，是否有应力迹象。这意味着如果玻璃中有应力，当你掉落它时，它基本上就会碎。所以它很脆弱。
Yeah, that's the characteristic of glass that I think of the most, that it is fairly fragile, but also can be strong. It's just like if it breaks it you know shatters and uh what was your favorite talk of the conference i think it was uh your talk actually oh my talk oh yeah how much how much did i pay you to say that well we we said we wouldn't discuss that but uh no i think it was uh why i liked it the best is because it's a topic that I never thought about before. So just the in-depth ordering of things and the sequence of operations that us. What guarantees do you actually get in that order?
是的，这是我想到玻璃时最先想到的特性，它相当脆弱，但也可能很坚固。只是如果它碎了，你知道，它会粉碎。你觉得这次会议上你最喜欢的演讲是什么？我想其实是你的演讲。哦，我的演讲？哦，是的。我付了你多少钱让你这么说？好吧，我们说过我们不会讨论这个，但是，不，我想是因为我最喜欢它，因为它是一个我以前从未想过的话题。就是对事物的深度排序以及我们操作的顺序。在那种顺序下你实际上得到了什么保证？
And I think the difference between happens before and happens before was really interesting. So it doesn't actually mean it will happen before in sequence in time, let's say. Yeah, that was really interesting. Well, Jason's talk was also interesting because of the way he specified the possible operations that you can do on types.
我认为“happens before”（先行发生）和“happens before”之间的区别真的很有趣。所以它并不真正意味着它会在时间顺序上先行发生，可以这么说。是的，那真的很有趣。嗯，Jason 的演讲也很有趣，因为他指定了你可以对类型执行的操作方式。
And it was really interesting to just sort of complete the circle between, yeah, I want my own unique type and I want to specify the operations on the type, but I don't want to go into a super complicated constexpr world of how to tell the compiler exactly what I mean. So this was a syntax that allows you to express what you want without knowing all the details of the template syntax behind it. So for background, for those who were not at the conference, I gave a talk about the C++ execution model where I actually go through and read a large chunk of the C++ standard that describes the execution model and then explain some of the implications and the real world impacts of what this all means. And then Jason gave a talk about...
把“我想要我自己的唯一类型”和“我想要指定该类型的操作”之间的圆环补全，这真的很有趣，但我不想进入一个超级复杂的 constexpr 世界，去告诉编译器我到底是什么意思。所以这是一种语法，允许你在不知道背后所有模板语法细节的情况下表达你想要的东西。作为背景，对于那些没参加会议的人，我做了一个关于 C++ 执行模型的演讲，我实际上通读并阅读了 C++ 标准中描述执行模型的一大块内容，然后解释了一些含义以及这一切在现实世界中的影响。然后 Jason 做了一个关于……
What did I give a talk about? Stronger typing. That's what it was about. And yes, as Jan said, I just really wanted to inspire people on why you want stronger typing in your code, but then I also showed some, I don't know, some goofy concepts, tricks, basically,
我做了关于什么的演讲？更强的类型系统。就是关于这个的。是的，正如 Jan 所说，我只是真的很想激励人们为什么要在代码中使用更强的类型系统，但我也展示了一些，我不知道，一些愚蠢的概念，基本上是一些技巧，
for how you might convince the compiler to implement those functions for you that you want on your strongly typed types. Your strong types? Anyhow, I think it was a pretty good talk. I think it worked out. I thought it was pretty good, yeah. I was finishing slides, so I was half there, half not. But we're passing this.
关于你如何说服编译器为你实现那些你想要在强类型上使用的函数。你的强类型？总之，我认为这是一个相当不错的演讲。我觉得效果很好。我也觉得很不错，是的。我当时在完成幻灯片，所以我一半在听，一半没在听。但我们正在通过这个。
Connor, you got things? And we've just slid past it. Fan favorite here, folks. Jason Turner. I was just about to say, you should introduce yourself. Host of CPPcast from, I believe, episode 4 to 359? 4? I don't know.
Connor，你有东西吗？我们刚刚滑过了它。各位，这是粉丝最爱。Jason Turner。我正要说，你应该自我介绍一下。CppCast 的主持人，我想是从第 4 集到第 359 集？4？我不知道。
349. And then guest co-host for 350 when we handed it off to Phil and Timur. This is true, and not only I mean, you're listening to a podcast right now so I'm sure there's like a 75% overlap
349。然后是第 350 集的客座联合主持人，当时我们把它交给了 Phil 和 Timur。这是真的，而且不仅是——我的意思是，你现在正在听一个播客，所以我确定我们的听众和 CppCast 有 75% 的重叠，
of our listeners with CPPcast but also according to your talk this morning, 454? 5? 455 weeks straight of C++ Weekly. Everyone's... 451? I don't... It's in that ball. North of 450, so we've got... And also north of 100,000 subscribers,
但根据你今天早上的演讲，454？5？连续 455 周的 C++ Weekly。每个人都……451？我不知道……大概在这个范围内。超过 450，所以我们有……而且还有超过 10 万订阅者，
you've got your silver YouTube play button. Has that arrived in the mail? Oh, yeah, yeah. I've had the silver play button for about a year now. Oh, okay. Okay. No, don't need to rub it in us other YouTubers' faces that haven't hit that milestone. How many subscribers do you have? I have less than 100,000.
你拿到了 YouTube 的白银创作者奖牌。那个寄到了吗？哦，是的，是的。我拿到白银奖牌大概一年了。哦，好的。好的。不需要在我们这些还没达到那个里程碑的 YouTube 博主面前炫耀。你有多少订阅者？我不到 10 万。
Okay, so an interesting thing here is I did a side series just on computer science topics for like five weeks or something. I did two episodes extra per week to try to just introduce other computer science topics for people who are interested in learning how to program. That massively hurt my channel. I went from an average of 1,000 new subscribers a month that I could count on down to 600 new subscribers a month when I was releasing new content to reach a wider audience. And it took about seven months for that to recover back up to 1,000 subscribers a month after I stopped that. What do you have theories as to why that was? Do you have theories as to why that was? Do you have theories? I think I just simply wasn't getting the C++ programmers subscribing anymore, and I was losing some subscribers who didn't want that extra content. It's a fun fact about YouTube subscribers is they're not willing
好的，这里有个有趣的事情，我做了一个专门讲计算机科学主题的副系列，大概持续了五周左右。我每周多做两集，试图为那些有兴趣学习编程的人介绍其他计算机科学主题。这严重伤害了我的频道。我从每个月可以指望的平均 1000 个新订阅者，下降到我发布新内容以触及更广泛受众时的每月 600 个新订阅者。在我停止那个系列后，花了大约七个月才恢复到每月 1000 个订阅者。你对为什么会这样有什么理论吗？你对为什么会这样有什么理论吗？你有什么理论吗？我想我只是简单地不再吸引 C++ 程序员订阅了，而且我失去了一些不想看那些额外内容的订阅者。关于 YouTube 订阅者，一个有趣的事实是他们不愿意
to simply skip videos that they don't like. I was once told, I got a comment on a YouTube video, because I change what I post videos on depending on what I'm interested in, and one of the comments I got once was, please stop holding us hostage with your array language content and go back to C++ algorithms. And it made me laugh so hard,
简单地跳过他们不喜欢的视频。我曾经被告知，我在一个 YouTube 视频下收到了一条评论，因为我根据我感兴趣的内容改变我发布视频的主题，我收到过的一条评论是：“请停止用你的数组语言内容绑架我们，回到 C++ 算法上来。”这让我笑得很大声，
because there's a subscribe button you can click to unsubscribe, and nobody's holding anybody hostage. Connor, you as a YouTuber should know. Don't tell them that there's a way to unsubscribe. Some of them may not know that they can unsubscribe. They may think it's a one-way door. That works in your favor.
因为有一个你可以点击取消订阅的按钮，没有人绑架任何人。Connor，作为一名 YouTube 博主，你应该知道。别告诉他们有一种取消订阅的方法。他们中的一些人可能不知道他们可以取消订阅。他们可能认为这是一扇单向门。这对你有利。
So you think you were upsetting folks that wanted purely C++ content, and somehow the algorithm figured that out? Although if I do occasional travel logs about places where C++ has taken me, I get pretty good responses to those, much lower views, but at least people aren't unsubscribing or complaining.
所以你认为你惹恼了那些只想要纯 C++ 内容的人，而算法不知何故发现了这一点？虽然如果我偶尔做一些关于 C++ 带我去过的地方的旅行日志，我会得到很好的回应，观看次数少得多，但至少人们不会取消订阅或抱怨。
I just start the episode by saying, hey, this is a travelogue. If you don't want to watch it, you should skip it. So, Connor, you should talk about your talk because I have an update on your talk. No, no, no. We'll talk about my talk later.
我只是在剧集开头说，嘿，这是一个旅行日志。如果你不想看，你应该跳过它。所以，Connor，你应该谈谈你的演讲，因为我有一个关于你演讲的更新。不，不，不。我们稍后再谈我的演讲。
Well, because Jason's got to bounce. He's heading back. We just talked about that. Both Jan and Jason are bouncing, which is why, I mean, we were looking for you at lunch. Then there was a break, but we didn't end up recording at the break. So now we're at the IMC sponsored.
好吧，因为 Jason 得走了。他要回去了。我们刚才谈到了这一点。Jan 和 Jason 都要走了，这就是为什么——我的意思是，我们在午餐时找你。然后有一个休息时间，但我们最终没有在休息时间录音。所以现在我们在 IMC 赞助的……
Yes, I was trying to avoid you. You were going to come up with an excuse, and then you realized, no, I wasn't doing anything. I was just actively avoiding these two that were hunting me down. I mean, fair enough, fair enough. We caught you, though. We caught the Pokemon before, I don't know, I didn't actually play Pokemon, so did they hop back into a forest or something?
是的，我当时在躲着你们。你本来要找个借口，然后你意识到，不，我什么都没做。我只是在积极躲避这两个追捕我的人。我的意思是，说得过去，说得过去。不过我们抓到你了。我们之前抓到了宝可梦，我不知道，我其实没玩过宝可梦，所以他们是跳回森林里去了还是怎么着？
You did not play Pokemon? I never played. I wasn't allowed to, no, yeah. That's true. I have played Pokemon Puzzle League, which was an N64 game, N64 game. That's the only Pokemon I've played, and it has nothing to do with Pokemon at all.
你没玩过宝可梦？我从来没玩过。我不被允许，不，是的。那是真的。我玩过《宝可梦益智联盟》，那是一款 N64 游戏，N64 游戏。那是我玩过的唯一一款宝可梦，而且它和宝可梦完全没关系。
I do know what's an N60. The N stands for Nintendo. Do you know which company makes the chips that go into the latest Nintendo product? Probably NVIDIA. That is correct. The NVIDIA Switch has an NVIDIA...
我知道什么是 N64。N 代表任天堂。你知道哪家公司制造了最新的任天堂产品里的芯片吗？可能是 NVIDIA。那是正确的。NVIDIA Switch 有一个 NVIDIA……
The Nintendo Switch has an NVIDIA chip in it. The NVIDIA Switch. All right, back to C++, though. So we were supposed to be introducing the esteemed Jason Turner, host of 350-plus podcasts, give or take, and 450-plus YouTube videos. I mean, the last time you were on ADSP was, I think, a couple years ago now. What have you been up to? I know
任天堂 Switch 里有一个 NVIDIA 芯片。NVIDIA Switch。好吧，回到 C++。所以我们本该介绍受人尊敬的 Jason Turner，350 多期播客的主持人，大概吧，还有 450 多部 YouTube 视频。我的意思是，你上次上 ADSP 大概是几年前了。你最近在忙什么？我知道
you've been traveling the world, coaching, training, giving keynotes, giving talks, anything you want to tell the C++ community, things you're excited about. I know you famously try not to take a look at C++ features until they're in the language, and you don't need to go to a fork on Compiler Explorer. But yeah, here's your opportunity, because I'm sure, as a fan of CppCast, the folks, they need a Jason Turner update. So, over to you. Well, I don't know if we're going to give a personal update or just a C++-y update. But yes, like you said, I've been doing a lot of travel this year.
你一直在环游世界，做教练、培训、做主题演讲、做演讲，有什么你想告诉 C++ 社区的事情吗？有什么让你兴奋的事情吗？我知道你很有名，尽量不看 C++ 特性，直到它们进入语言标准，你不需要去 Compiler Explorer 上看分支。但是的，这是你的机会，因为我确定，作为 CppCast 的粉丝，大家需要一个 Jason Turner 的更新。所以，交给你了。好吧，我不知道我们要给一个个人更新还是一个 C++ 相关的更新。但是的，就像你说的，我今年做了很多旅行。
And where have you been? Where have I... You can hold the mic. And And he goes, where have you been? Where have I? You can hold the mic. And you can give us whatever updates you feel like sharing. Where have I been this year is the question, perhaps. I don't know. I've been to Canada. I've been to Norway, Netherlands.
你去过哪里？我去过哪里……你可以拿着麦克风。他说，你去过哪里？我去过哪里？你可以拿着麦克风。你可以给我们任何你想分享的更新。也许问题是我今年去过哪里。我不知道。我去过加拿大。我去过挪威、荷兰。
I've been to a lot of U.S. states. CBP Con. Yeah, well, I've been to CBP Con. Yes. Why did you say it like that? Because that's my hometown. CBP Con. CBP Con. I don't even know. I honestly would have to look at my calendar right now. This is almost pre-COVID travel for me. It's one transatlantic trip away from being pre-COVID travel. That's where i'm at right now and as you said i do famously avoid the not things that aren't standardized it's very very rare for me to put something in a c++ weekly episode that is not standardized i'm not going to waste the mental
我去过很多美国州。C++ Con。是的，好吧，我去过 C++ Con。是的。你为什么那样说？因为那是我的家乡。C++ Con。C++ Con。我甚至不知道。老实说，我现在得看看我的日历。这对我来说几乎是 COVID 前的旅行频率。离 COVID 前的旅行频率只差一次跨大西洋旅行。这就是我现在的状态，正如你所说，我确实很有名地避免那些没有标准化的东西。在 C++ Weekly 的剧集中放入非标准化的东西对我来说非常非常罕见。我不会浪费脑力
cycles on this because i don't know what it's going to end up being and i will say at cvp con i saw a couple of talks on reflection which i I'm like, I was very not excited about this. They were all like, they're all like, oh, and look with a bunch of syntax that you can't read, you can magically make things. And I just, it was lost on me, honestly. But in balls closing keynote actually broke this feature down in a way that was very digestible. And I'm like, you know what?'m actually i'm more excited about this now i mean i've wanted reflection this whole time because i've done i'm wearing my chai script t-shirt right now it's vintage for listeners who know anything about chai
在这些事情上，因为我不知道它最终会变成什么样。我要说的是，在 C++ Con 上，我看了几个关于反射的演讲，我当时想，我对这个非常不兴奋。他们都像，他们都像，“哦，看，用一堆你读不懂的语法，你可以神奇地制造出东西。”老实说，我没听懂。但在 Inbal 的闭幕主题演讲中，她实际上以一种非常易于消化的方式分解了这个特性。我当时想，你知道吗？我现在对这个更兴奋了。我的意思是，我一直想要反射，因为我做过——我现在穿着我的 ChaiScript T 恤，对于知道 Chai 的听众来说，这是复古的
script i haven't maintained it in a long time but i am uh i've always been excited about reflection because it would make things like scripting bindings much easier. And so I'm looking forward to this. But the versions of it that I've seen on slides, I wasn't excited about. And watch one of InBall's talks. I'll tell the community, watch one of InBall's talks. She breaks it down better than anyone else I've seen so far. I've
脚本，我已经很久没维护它了，但我一直对反射很兴奋，因为它会让脚本绑定之类的事情变得容易得多。所以我很期待这个。但我在幻灯片上看到的那些版本，我并不兴奋。去看看 Inbal 的演讲之一。我会告诉社区，去看看 Inbal 的演讲之一。她比我目前看到的任何人都解释得更好。我
given a couple talks, well, I've had a section of a talk on reflection on my C++ Horizons talk for a while, and I recently had a section of a talk on reflection on my C++ Horizons talk for a while. And I recently had to remake it because they changed some of the syntax. The token sequences stuff came out specifically. And I wanted to remake it for the token sequences. And I went from being kind of meh on the examples.
做过几次演讲，好吧，我的 C++ Horizons 演讲中有一部分关于反射的内容已经有一段时间了，我最近不得不重做它，因为他们改变了一些语法。标记序列（token sequences）的东西特别出来了。我想为标记序列重做它。我从对这些例子感觉一般，
They worked, but they weren't... It's the sign when you go to the slide, like, people growing in the audience. Like, it does something cool. But then, like, I rewrote them with the token sequences stuff. And I was, like, very happy. Like, happy enough where I was, like, I should go make a whole talk just on reflection. Like, I feel like reflection has been sort of iterated for a while. There's been a lot of churn, and some of the earlier ideas were a little bit clunkier. But the four minutes in now, I'm excited about it.
它们能用，但它们不是……当你看到幻灯片时，就像观众在呻吟。就像，它做了一些很酷的事情。但后来，我用标记序列的东西重写了它们。我当时非常高兴。高兴到我当时想，我应该专门做一个关于反射的演讲。我觉得反射已经迭代了一段时间了。有很多变动，早期的一些想法有点笨拙。但现在四分钟过去了，我很兴奋。
I'm excited about its NixOS feature. All right, so I'm going to jet. All right. Thank you so much for talking to us. Before you jet, last thing, do you know, do you have your next conference slash training? If folks are looking to attend one of your training courses and have in the past, do you know? Or potentially the answer is, I have no more conferences lined up 2025 or the next time you'll see me. If you do though,
我对它的 NixOS 特性很兴奋。好吧，我要走了。好的。非常感谢你和我们交谈。在你走之前，最后一件事，你知道，你有下一个会议或培训吗？如果人们想参加你的培训课程，并且过去参加过，你知道吗？或者潜在的答案是，我没有安排 2025 年的会议，或者你下次见到我的时候。如果确实有的话，
now's your chance to let people know. You can look for workshops for me potentially at CBPCon, IndyC Tech Town, C++ Under the Sea, C++ Unsea. I don't have any of that lined up yet because none of those things have been set in stone yet. I will be at Code Dive in Wrocław, Poland in five, six weeks from now. Yes. So I will see those of you there who are there. I'm sorry.
现在是让人们知道的机会。你可以在 C++ Con、IndyC Tech Town、C++ Under the Sea、C++ Unsea 寻找我的研讨会。我还没有安排任何这些，因为这些事情都没有确定下来。我五六周后会去波兰弗罗茨瓦夫的 Code Dive。是的。所以我会在那里见到你们。抱歉。
And perfect timing. Speak of the devil. Miss Inval, we need you. Inval Levy just came over here, and she has now fleeing. And Jason Turner just had a lot of lovely things to say about your talk. Oh, Jonathan wants to say something. Yeah, go for it. I want to clarify some of my earlier statements.
时机完美。说曹操，曹操就到。Inbal 女士，我们需要你。Inbal Levy 刚才过来了，她现在要逃跑了。Jason Turner 刚才对你的演讲说了许多好话。哦，Jonathan 想说点什么。是的，说吧。我想澄清一下我之前的一些言论。
For legal reasons, I have to say those were jokes. I like all podcasts equally well, and they do not represent my actual opinion. Wait, I don't even remember. What did you say that was problematic? I said nothing. I did not say anything. I don't recall. I don I recall. I recall.
出于法律原因，我必须说那些是开玩笑的。我同样喜欢所有的播客，它们不代表我的真实观点。等等，我甚至不记得了。你说了什么有问题的话？我什么都没说。我什么都没说。我不记得了。我记得。我记得。
Jonathan said that he loves our podcast so much and other C++ podcast sluts. We have Inbo Levy right here. Jason Turner just said that Inbo's talk on reflection is the first talk that made him excited about reflection. Miss Levy, come over here. Introduce yourself to the listeners. I do not know where Connor is. He has abandoned me. I'm not sure if the equipment's working.
Jonathan 说他非常喜欢我们的播客和其他 C++ 播客。我们这里有 Inbal Levy。Jason Turner 刚才说 Inbal 关于反射的演讲是第一个让他对反射感到兴奋的演讲。Levy 女士，过来这里。向听众介绍一下你自己。我不知道 Connor 在哪里。他抛弃了我。我不确定设备是否在工作。
Here is Inval. Inval, introduce yourself. Before that, I'll just say that sometimes you just wander into areas and you just, you know, you regret that. But hi, Bryce. Thank you for bringing me up live. It's very exciting or recorded or whatever. Yeah, it was really fun talk. I wish I had more time.
这是 Inbal。Inbal，介绍一下你自己。在那之前，我只想说，有时你只是漫步到某些领域，然后你只是，你知道，你会后悔。但你好，Bryce。谢谢你让我现场直播。这非常令人兴奋，或者录音，或者其他什么。是的，这是一个非常有趣的演讲。我希望我有更多时间。
I know that some people have overtook the time in the talks before me. But that's fine because their talk was also fascinating. Now, I think they were unfair to you because part of the way through your talk, you asked how much time you had left. And someone said that you had until 6 p.m. And I was a little surprised because I looked at the schedule and I was like, that doesn't seem right. And then you continued going
我知道有些人占用了我之前的演讲时间。但这没关系，因为他们的演讲也很迷人。现在，我认为他们对你不公平，因为在你的演讲进行到一半时，你问还剩多少时间。有人说你一直到下午 6 点。我有点惊讶，因为我看了时间表，我想，那看起来不对。然后你继续讲，
and then somebody holds up a sign telling you you have 10 minutes left. And like, understandably, like that's a little unfair. Somebody, you asked how much time you had. Somebody said you had until 6. And then it's like 5.25 and they're like, that's a little unfair. Somebody, you asked how much time you had. Somebody said you had until 6. And then it's, like, 5.25, and they're, like, time to wrap it up. I think that's unreasonable. Yeah, I haven't the second time, actually, once.
然后有人举起牌子告诉你还剩 10 分钟。而且，可以理解，这有点不公平。有人，你问你有多少时间。有人说你一直到 6 点。然后是 5 点 25 分，他们说，这有点不公平。有人，你问你有多少时间。有人说你一直到 6 点。然后是 5 点 25 分，他们说，是时候结束了。我认为这不合理。是的，我实际上有第二次，一次。
But I wonder. You said you had until 6. The organizers, I think. Yeah, somebody from the audience said you got until 6. No, no, it was actually one of the organizers. But that's fine. That's fine. I really appreciate, you know, them giving me the opportunity. I'm really excited of the organizers. But that's fine. That's fine. I really appreciate them giving me the opportunity.
但我很好奇。你说你一直到 6 点。组织者，我想。是的，观众席里的某个人说你一直到 6 点。不，不，实际上是组织者之一。但这没关系。但这没关系。我真的很感激，你知道，他们给了我这个机会。我真的很兴奋组织者。但这没关系。但这没关系。我真的很感激他们给了我这个机会。
I'm really excited about Reflection. And one thing I do want to say is that I'm not actually the author of this. And there's a bunch of other people that I've mentioned in my talk, like Barry and David, that have been working on this really, really hard. And Dan Katz, of course, for implementing this in Clang. And those people are actually the people that need to be chaired. And I believe that Miss Daisy Holman is currently actively working on implementing token sequences in Clang. And I believe she is live streaming that on Twitch.
我对反射非常兴奋。我想说的一件事是，我实际上不是这个的作者。我在演讲中提到了其他很多人，比如 Barry 和 David，他们一直在非常非常努力地工作。当然还有 Dan Katz，因为他在 Clang 中实现了这个。这些人才是真正需要被称赞的人。我相信 Daisy Holman 女士目前正在积极致力于在 Clang 中实现标记序列。我相信她正在 Twitch 上直播。
So if you're interested, go check out her Twitch account, which I would guess would be the whole Daisy. That is her Twitter handle. But I would guess would be the whole daisy that is her Twitter handle, but I saw that earlier this week. Well, we'll put a link in the description. If that's not accurate, just go to the show notes. There'll be a link. And token sequences, no, we're not done with it yet. I got one more thing.
所以如果你感兴趣，去看看她的 Twitch 账号，我猜会是 whole daisy。那是她的 Twitter 账号。但我猜会是 whole daisy，那是她的 Twitter 账号，但我本周早些时候看到了。好吧，我们会把链接放在描述里。如果那不准确，就去看看节目笔记。会有链接的。还有标记序列，不，我们还没讲完。我还有一件事。
So I was just telling a story that I was remaking some of my slides on reflection for token sequences, because some of the stuff, the way you do some things that change with the addition of token sequences. And I was very happy with the result. And I was wondering, have you looked at the token sequences part much? What do you think of it? We haven't looked at it at all, in fact. So I'll be happy to see your talk I actually haven't gave a lot of thought to that
所以我刚才讲了一个故事，我正在为标记序列重做我的一些关于反射的幻灯片，因为有些东西，你做某些事情的方式随着标记序列的加入而改变了。我对结果非常满意。我想知道，你对标记序列部分看过很多吗？你觉得它怎么样？事实上，我们根本没看过。所以我很高兴看到你的演讲，我实际上没怎么考虑过那个，
so I don't have anything smart to say how is library evolution going? for those who do not know Inba Levy is the chair of library evolution where she is doing a wonderful job and producing a ton of excellent
所以我没什么聪明的话可说。库进化（Library Evolution）进展如何？对于那些不知道的人，Inbal Levy 是库进化小组的主席，她做得非常出色，并产生了大量优秀的工作，
work that's all going to go into C++26. So what do you have to say, Inbal? What's on the horizon? I just want to say before that, that everything that goes wrong, you can blame my previous chair, which you just heard. I completely agree with that sentiment. Everything right is Inbal's success, and everything wrong is a righteous failure. Yes, I think I heard Jason saying some things that went wrong. It goes great.
所有这些都将进入 C++26。那么，Inbal，你有什么要说的吗？地平线上有什么？在那之前，我只想说，所有出错的事情，你都可以责怪我上一任主席，你刚才听到了。我完全同意这种观点。所有正确的事情都是 Inbal 的成功，所有错误的事情都是正义的失败。是的，我想我听到 Jason 说了一些出错的事情。进展很顺利。
It's going on great. We're working really hard. I just had, in this conference yesterday, after my flight and got some time to rest, we had a reflection meeting. So we're really, really working hard to get everything in time for 26, which is exciting. And I am super excited about the amount of time and energy that people in the committee are actually giving to get C++ 26 in good shape on time. So I think it's amazing. What features do you think are likely to be big things that we'll see in 29 from the library side? Maybe Mathieu should be a bit upset to hear, but I think units are probably not going to make it to 26.
进展很顺利。我们正在非常努力地工作。我昨天在这个会议上，在我的航班之后，有了一些休息时间，我们开了一个反射会议。所以我们真的真的在努力工作，以便及时完成 26 的所有工作，这很令人兴奋。我超级兴奋于委员会成员实际上投入的时间和精力，以使 C++ 26 按时处于良好状态。所以我认为这太棒了。你认为哪些特性很可能是我们在 29 年从库方面看到的重大事项？也许 Mathieu 听到会有点难过，但我认为单位（units）可能不会进入 26。
So I'd expect them to go into 29. And I think units is actually very significant for some domains. And I'm expecting this to land. So we had a question the other day, which is, is there an SI unit equivalent of knots? Right? Knots is the distance of measurement, but it's nautical, so it's kind of curved,
所以我预计它们会进入 29。而且我认为单位对于某些领域来说实际上非常重要。我期待着它落地。所以我们前几天有一个问题，就是，有没有节（knots）的 SI 单位等价物？对吧？节是测量距离，但它是航海的，所以它有点弯曲，
and it's in terms of miles. And I don't know know is there an si equivalent not somebody somebody tell me let's let's let's call coon good i'm gonna go you're gonna go grab so this is this is not gonna be coon's first time on the podcast this will not be coon's first time so if well she said she was gonna go get him and then she ran right by him. Bryce is going to go get him. So I believe it was episode 196 plus or minus one when Tristan brought to CPP North a video with Kuhn in the recording. Bryce is disappearing, but he did send Kuhn over. He's sitting down now. We have just wrapped.
而且是以英里为单位的。我不知道有没有 SI 等价物，节，有人，有人告诉我。让我们，让我们叫上 Koen。我要去，你要去抓……所以这不是 Koen 第一次上播客，这不会是 Koen 第一次。所以如果，好吧，她说她要去叫他，然后她直接从他身边跑过去了。Bryce 要去叫他。所以我想是在第 196 集左右，当时 Tristan 给 C++ North 带了一段有 Koen 在录音里的视频。Bryce 正在消失，但他确实把 Koen 叫过来了。他现在坐下了。我们刚刚结束。
I think I mentioned this earlier. We're now at the IMC post-conference social. I actually can't tell. It looks like many people have left, but there are still quite a few here. And now we're here with Kuhn. Introduce yourself, second time on the podcast, but first time in person. Introduce yourself, tell us what you thought about the conference and anything else you want to share with us. Well, so my name is Koen, I'm from Belgium. I've been working on C++ for the first time about 20 years ago. You look so young.
我想我之前提到过这一点。我们现在在 IMC 会议后社交活动上。我其实看不出来。看起来很多人已经离开了，但这里还有不少人。现在我们和 Koen 在一起。介绍一下你自己，第二次上播客，但第一次面对面。介绍一下你自己，告诉我们你对这次会议的看法以及任何你想和我们分享的其他事情。好吧，我叫 Koen，我来自比利时。我大约 20 年前第一次开始从事 C++ 工作。你看上去真年轻。
20 years ago? Yeah. Well, I can't say that the code I wrote then was actually good, but it was really embarrassing if I look back to it. But anyhow, so now I'm also a full-time C++ developer, and I'm loving the conference, having seen a lot of great talks, gained some new ideas, so that's really great. I'm happy to be here and to meet my heroes, of course. Well, Bryce is putting up a finger.
20 年前？是的。好吧，我不能说我当时写的代码真的很好，但如果我回顾过去，那真的很尴尬。但无论如何，现在我也是一名全职 C++ 开发人员，我很喜欢这次会议，看到了很多很棒的演讲，获得了一些新想法，所以这真的很棒。我很高兴来到这里，当然也见到了我的英雄们。好吧，Bryce 竖起了一根手指。
My mother is having travel difficulties trying to return to Tampa post-hurricane. I have to check whether her flight's going to leave. All right. So Bryce is going to be a bit MIA. You just wrapped. You say you had some interesting ideas. What would you say was the most interesting idea slash most interesting talk that you saw during the conference? And keep in mind, there was, what, two keynotes and four, two tracks and four talks on each track. So if you went to every single slot, you've only got six talks to choose from.
我母亲在飓风后试图返回坦帕时遇到了旅行困难。我得检查一下她的航班是否会起飞。好吧。所以 Bryce 会有点失踪。你刚才结束了。你说你有一些有趣的想法。你会说你在会议期间看到的最有趣的想法或最有趣的演讲是什么？请记住，有，什么，两个主题演讲和四个，两个轨道，每个轨道四个演讲。所以如果你参加了每一个时段，你只有六个演讲可以选择。
So it's not like we're at the end of a five-day, you know, conference here. So yeah, share some of the interesting ideas that you came away with. There was one talk before lunch about logging in a high-frequency trading application. And actually, I also submitted a talk related to logging and performance of logging. So that was really close to my heart. And it had some quite interesting ideas to switch on and off logging
所以我们并不是在一个五天会议的结尾。所以，是的，分享一些你从中获得的有意思的想法。午餐前有一个关于在高频交易应用程序中进行日志记录的演讲。实际上，我也提交了一个关于日志记录和日志记录性能的演讲。所以那真的很贴近我的心。它有一些相当有趣的想法来开启和关闭日志记录，
to minimize the logging calls that were not interesting for you at that point of time. So to reduce the impact, to increase the frequency of trading. So that was really interesting to hear. What C++ standard are you working with at your job? Slash maybe in personal projects as well? It might be different. In personal projects, I would say C++ 20. But as I'm developing for an embedded system, our tool chains are a bit behind,
以最大限度地减少你在那个时间点不感兴趣的日志调用。从而减少影响，提高交易频率。所以听到这个真的很有趣。你在工作中使用的 C++ 标准是什么？或者个人项目中也可能不同。在个人项目中，我会说 C++ 20。但由于我正在为嵌入式系统开发，我们的工具链有点落后，
so that's still C++ 11. So I'm not really able to use the more recent features, although that would help out in certain situations to make the code more readable and more performant perhaps. Do you want to share or I'm not sure if you're able to, we can cut this out, what you do for work in embedded systems? Because I'm sure we have
所以那仍然是 C++ 11。所以我真的无法使用更新的特性，尽管在某些情况下这会有助于使代码更具可读性和性能。你想分享吗，或者我不确定你是否能，我们可以剪掉这个，你在嵌入式系统中做什么工作？因为我确定我们有
quite a few listeners that do embedded work. I know Ben Dean, he also works at Intel in embedded systems. So, I mean, we definitely have people that work in that space and are probably curious when you mention that you're doing C++11 in embedded. What is that? So I work for a company called Van der Wielen,
不少听众做嵌入式工作。我知道 Ben Dean，他也在 Intel 从事嵌入式系统工作。所以，我的意思是，我们肯定有在那个领域工作的人，并且当你提到你在嵌入式中使用 C++ 11 时，他们可能会感到好奇。那是什么？所以我为一家叫 Van der Wielen 的公司工作，
and we make carpet machines or textile machines, actually. But one of our most important products are carpet machines. So actually, the one that is laying over there, there's a quite significant probability that it was made on one of our machines. It's another name that you see, of course, because we don't produce the carpets, but we make the machines to do it. And I'm responsible for the HMI team. So the screens that are next to the machines that decide which carpets you're going to make,
我们制造地毯机器或纺织机器，实际上。但我们最重要的产品之一是地毯机器。所以实际上，铺在那里的那台，它是在我们的机器上制造的概率相当大。当然，你看到的是另一个名字，因为我们不生产地毯，但我们制造生产地毯的机器。我负责 HMI 团队。所以机器旁边的屏幕决定了你要制造什么样的地毯，
all the settings, the reporting of of errors logging all the monitoring of the machines and how they are running is so that's my core function i am glad my girlfriend is not here because she has recently become obsessed with cloth work i'm talking needlepoint knitting crochet you name it she is currently weaving weaving. She is currently producing it. And it is rapidly filling up our apartment. And the last thing I need is for her to want to buy an industrial carpet making machine. However, it is quite a nice carpet. Are you running in an embedded environment without an OS? No, this is a slimmed down Linux version. So did you already get rid of your coffee table? We did get rid of the coffee table, and it just ended up,
所有的设置，错误的报告，日志记录，所有机器的监控以及它们的运行方式，所以这是我的核心职能。我很高兴我女朋友不在这里，因为她最近迷上了布艺。我说的是针绣、编织、钩针，随你怎么说。她目前正在织布。她目前正在生产它。它正在迅速填满我们的公寓。我最不需要的就是她想买一台工业地毯制造机。不过，那确实是一块不错的地毯。你在没有操作系统的嵌入式环境中运行吗？不，这是一个精简版的 Linux 版本。所以你已经处理掉你的咖啡桌了吗？我们确实处理掉了咖啡桌，它最终，
I just put a thing out on Facebook Marketplace, and somebody was going to come over, and there was a mix-up with the doorman where they were going to give her the coffee table because we were already moved out. But then there was some mix-up and she was real upset because they they told her oh it's not here and then she had to come back a second day and i felt really bad but uh yes it is now in a better home and i uh i hope it has not been
我只是在 Facebook Marketplace 上发了一个东西，有人要过来，门卫搞混了，他们要把咖啡桌给她，因为我们已经搬走了。但后来出了一些差错，她真的很生气，因为他们告诉她“哦，它不在这里”，然后她不得不第二天再来，我感到非常抱歉，但是的，它现在在一个更好的家里，我希望它没有被
i don't know sold for scrap i don't think it has value with scrap so i'm just going to choose to believe it's in a better home you've baited you've baited b, you know. We were on topic, C++, and you baited him with a furniture question. That's real evil of you, Coon. That's real evil. Coming on, first time in person, baiting Bryce like that with a furniture question. He's already doing travel stuff on his phone,
我不知道，当作废品卖掉。我不认为它作为废品有价值，所以我只是选择相信它在一个更好的家里。你诱导了，你诱导了 B，你知道。我们本来在讨论 C++，你用一个家具问题诱导了他。你真坏，Koen。你真坏。第一次面对面来，用家具问题那样诱导 Bryce。他已经在手机上处理旅行事务了，
and now you're confusing him. He doesn't know, do I focus on travel or do I focus on furniture? The mother is good. I wanted to end up in the 10x section as well. Another thing that was really striking was during your talk, you mentioned the work of Tristan Brindle with the Flux library and the performance of it. So I was really blown away by that.
现在你让他困惑了。他不知道，我该关注旅行还是关注家具？母亲很好。我也想在 10 倍部分结束。另一件非常引人注目的事情是，在你的演讲中，你提到了 Tristan Brindle 在 Flux 库方面的工作以及它的性能。所以我真的被震撼了。
So that's also something I want to look at and see if that's... Yeah, we are going to be having Tristan on. I mean, I mentioned this a couple episodes ago. I was supposed to record with him live in Rickmansworth. I have to remember that is the municipality that he lives in. But Taylor Swift, she messed up the subways with her Wembley Stadium performance. And we ended up being short on time, so we didn't end up recording. But I told them that we would bring them on to get some Flux updates.
所以这也是我想看看并看看是否……是的，我们将邀请 Tristan。我的意思是，我几集前提到过这一点。我本该在 Rickmansworth 和他现场录音。我得记住那是他居住的城市。但 Taylor Swift，她在温布利球场的表演搞乱了地铁。我们最终时间不够，所以没有录音。但我告诉他们，我们会邀请他们来获取一些 Flux 更新。
But yes, Flux, you heard it here first, folks. Or maybe you heard it in Tristan's talk first. Flux is faster. You should go use Flux. And also, too, because it's not a standard library, if you've got some algorithm that you want that doesn't exist, you can just go create an issue, potentially even go try and implement it yourself
但是的，Flux，你们在这里第一次听到了，各位。或者也许你在 Tristan 的演讲中第一次听到了。Flux 更快。你应该去使用 Flux。而且，因为这不是标准库，如果你有你想要的算法不存在，你可以直接去创建一个 issue，甚至可以尝试自己去实现它，
and get a little mentorship. But if not, I mean, Tristan has always been pretty... At one point, they didn't have... I want to say adjacent map. They didn't have some function. And one of those things where I didn't mean to nerdsnipe him, but I was just like, oh, it's missing this. And then like four days later, it had it.
并获得一点指导。但如果没有，我的意思是，Tristan 一直很……有一次，他们没有……我想说相邻映射（adjacent map）。他们没有某个函数。那是那种我不是故意要对他进行“书呆子狙击”（nerdsnipe），但我只是说，哦，它缺少这个。然后大概四天后，它就有了。
Bryce is trying to say something. Yes, I think given that the subject of your talk has been brought up and I have some fun things to mention about your talk that you should give a brief overview of what your talk was about. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Bryce 试图说点什么。是的，我想鉴于你的演讲主题已经被提出来了，而且我有一些关于你的演讲的有趣的事情要提，你应该简要概述一下你的演讲内容。请务必在你的播客应用程序或 ADSP the podcast.com 上查看这些节目笔记，以获取我们在今天剧集中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高数量。那是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。